Juan Carlos chamaya works as a security
guard in an upscale Santiago
neighborhood he voted for social reforms
and for leftist president Gabrielle
boric just a year ago but now he's one
of millions of Chileans who've shifted
to the far right
the issue of crimes the reason the
Republican party for a long time has
shown it would take a hard-line stance
we elected the left out of
sentimentality big mistake
ultra-conservative Republican party was
the standard Bearer in an electoral
campaign for a new constitutional
Council that astutely focused on the
issue that's become a top priority in
Chile crime a mass influx of
undocumented migrants and drug
trafficking
but they're not problems fixed by a
constitution says lawyer Passat but
Chileans took the bait and people really
were boating voting for Brands political
brands and there was one brand for
security another brand for perhaps a
kind of an old-fashioned socialism and
they prefer this time the brand that
promotes security at all cost and they
didn't care very much about what they're
going to do in this process the
Constitutional process
perhaps but the Republican party will be
calling the shots with the power to veto
any proposal it chooses
this is particularly unsettling as the
country commemorates the 50th
anniversary of a military coup that
turned into a 17-year dictatorship
headed by General agusto Pinochet
there is the party that most Faithfully
represents the legacy of Pinochet the
only one that speaks out publicly to
defend the former dictator
muser is the political Center which
suffered the worst electoral losses in
three decades
inside the presidential Palace the
election is being felt like a category
10 earthquake without a majority in
Congress left-wing president Gabriel
boric will have an even more difficult
time passing his ambitious social agenda
and even though he has three more years
to go some are already calling him a
lame duck president
putting on a brave face boric called on
the Republican party to exercise
moderation and Prudence but as many
point out neither he nor political
moderates are in a position to ask for
favors anymore
to see a Newman Al Jazeera Santiago